hey guys welcome back to new rockstars
I'm Sam basher here with one of my
patented not MCU re-watch breakdown tray
I'm very excited today because we're
gonna be talking about one of my
all-time favorite action films Captain
America the Winter Soldier before we get
started quickly spoiler warning for the
cat films the MCU the Capcom excetera
let's begin kicking it off with comic
book Easter eggs opening on a beautiful
sunrise we meet Sam Wilson aka the
Falcon he first appeared in Captain
America at number 117 in September 1969
now he originally was a villain Danny
was turned into a hero and his wing at
harness you see in the comics originally
was created and given to him by Black
Panther which is pretty cool also
usually he has the ability to
telepathically communicate with birds in
the comics actually find in fact Red
Skull in the comics uses the Cosmic Cube
to give Sam Wilson the ability to talk
to birds sorry to be the life in the
middle of that it's just ridiculous
they're moving forward to our first
mission they're headed to the Lunarian
star now this is actually a very deep
cut because not many Marvel fans even
know about lumeria
it's actually an underwater like
civilization on earth similar to
Atlantis next we meet one of my favorite
characters from the MCU and comics
crossbones aka Brock rumlow one of the
coolest names ever his first appearance
was in Captain America number 360 in
October of 1989 now originally he was a
soldier and mercenary he get hired out
by a Red Skull Baron Zemo whatever bad
guy he work for him they're moving
forward to our very first villain of the
film george Batroc who in the comics is
actually his name is usually just Batroc
the leaper who appeared in tales of
suspense number 75 in March of 1966 also
he's played by st. Pierre who's a
real-life MMA fighter who I would not
want to be kicked by him that would not
be fun before DC captain jump right out
of a plane without a parachute which is
from the opening scene from The
Ultimates comics which is a reimagining
of the Avengers in a new universe it's
one of the coolest scenes from that
comic it's one of the coolest scenes in
the MCU also just want to point out that
caps new costume is actually a nod to
The Secret Avengers costume I'm actually
really big fan of it I like just the
blue and the white think it's very cool
moving forward to hear Black Widow
mentioned the nurse that lives across
the hall
across the hall from you she seemed nice
already hinting to Sharon Carter but
we'll come back to her in just a second
next we see the Triskelion the
headquarters for shield in this universe
and in the Ultimate Universe comics
which is pretty cool that's where it was
created eventually moving over to the
main comics universe I'm a big fan of
the name and the whole set up I think
it's very cool then we see Nick Fury for
the first time in this film and he
mentions that the last time he trusted
someone he lost an eye now in the comics
he loses his one eye because of shrapnel
from a bomb hits him right now right in
the peeper but in the movies it's a
mystery it might just always be a
mystery might be just one thread too
many for those MCU writers moving
forward again we get a nod to the
repulsor technology from Iron Man they
even say that Stark helps put the
repulsor engines in these new
helicarriers which is a fun fact because
originally in the comics Tony Stark
created the Helicarrier he designed them
for shield
Ned moving for two Robert Redford's
character secretary Alexander Pierce's
actually from the comics but he's
totally different he actually appears in
Nick Fury vs shield number three in
August of 1988 and he's mainly just an
expert spy next we get an extremely
awesome scene with Nick Fury taking on a
bunch of Hydra agents in the middle of
Washington DC you hear him try to tell
his AI and his car to take a vertical
takeoff which is a fun nod to two
different things in the comics where
Nick Fury actually has a flying card
that he uses all the time and most
shield agents actually use them in the
comics but also in the first Captain
America movie we see Howard Stark
showing off some new propulsion car tech
the Mixit hover just a little bit which
actually leads us to they deep view of
the Winter Soldier now Winter Soldier
specifically appeared in Captain America
number one in January 2005 now Bucky
appeared all the way back in the 40s but
we've talked about him in the first
Captain America movie breakdown you
should go check that out for more on
Bucky before the Winter Soldier we find
out that when he and cap were sitting on
a drone back in the 40s and ends up
exploding in that same explosion throws
cap into the Arctic where he freezes and
eventually wakes up in the present day
same thing
Bucky gets thrown to the water as well
but he loses an arm but ends up being
scooped up by Soviet scientists then he
gets experimented on gets a new metal
arm and he basically becomes the Soviet
version of Captain
America then we get the official reveal
of his neighbor being agent 13 aka
Sharon Carter who first appeared in
tales of suspense number 75 in March of
1966 then Oh sad face Nick Fury dies
question mark just a little bit
now his Nick Fury died in the comics
probably in some way and has come back
in a different way right now he's living
on the moon he's chained to it what a
what a wonderful world comics are moving
on I just wanted to mention when Black
Widow and Captain America having this
intimate moment where they're getting
angry and breathing in on each other's
faces and I think kind of made me think
of like what have they dated oh don't
worry they definitely dated many times
in comics actually Black Widow has dated
many people who are in this movie just
wanted to mention really quick that this
elevator scene where they fight here's
the clip whoo it's just awesome moving
on then we get cap jumping out of the
elevator down to the floor below he
falls white away is and it kind of seems
like a nod to these Civil War comic
ruins of actually jumping out of a
helicopter
oh my god that was so cool they're
moving forward to the army base we run
into Armand Zola we talked about Armand
Zola and all of his Easter eggs in the
first Captain America video go check
that out but I think this is the coolest
way to adapt his Android computer mind
thing to the real world then moving
forward to the Sitwell interrogation you
hear him mention the sorcerer supreme
himself Stephen strange now at the time
it has been confirmed that he was not
the sorcerer supreme yet but we did hear
that the Zola algorithm was going to
look for potential threats in the future
and Kevin Feige has come forward to say
that because of that eventually Stephen
strange would have become a threat
because he is rich and he's powerful and
he's always mingling with prominent
people eventually he could know too much
and then we get Bucky versus cap and
there are three little specific scenes
right here that are directly pulled from
the comics first one
Bucky punching the shield boom copy
pasted right there also Bucky holding
the shield this is actually a nod to
when Bucky became Captain America
nicknamed Bucky cap and finally who the
hell is Bucky that line is directly
pulled from the comics it's a great line
they've been moving forward to when we
find out that her aide Nick Fury's not
dead he's in one of his secret bunkers
that is a classic story beat in all of
Marvel's comics Nick Fury has secret
bases all over the planet I also want to
mention during this memory-wipe scene
for Bucky if you noticed this man with
the unbuttoned collared white shirt that
is actually the creator of the Winter
Soldier that's mister edy Brubaker
then we get crossbones the Falcon what a
great match and even get a fun not to
crossbones the name in his costume with
those straps on his chest also Falcon
and cap teaming up to take down a Hydra
they do that for decades in the comics
it was so cool to see them choose to
work together in this movie then we get
her first post-credit scene with Baron
von Strucker who first appeared in
sergeant fury in his Howling Commandos
number five in January 1964 he's the
leader of Hydra usually has who in
children a boy and a girl who when they
put their hands together become ultra
powerful but we actually get a different
set of twins
that's right Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch now Quicksilver made his first
appearance in x-men number four in March
of 1964 and shocker
so did Scarlet Witch because they're
twins but I'll talk about them more when
we get to age of Ultron speaking of age
of Ultron let's talk about some MCU
Easter eggs yes please right up top we
get Marvel's intro 2.0 a big fan
this one also this is so cool I love
this attention to detail in these Marvel
movies remember Steve's list of
everything that he needs to catch up on
well in every country that this was
released for the most part that list was
different for the u.s. one we saw I Love
Lucy we saw the moon landing Berlin Wall
up down Cold War Steve Jobs but for the
UK there was the Sherlock TV show The
Beatles the World Cup final in 1966 in
Australia there was ac/dc space travel
Steve Irwin and Skippy the bush kangaroo
they're moving forward to the
Smithsonian you actually see Joss Whedon
in this scene in the very far background
you see him going down the escalator
right there then we go to the same camp
that was in the first cat movie that one
where cap actually trained to be cap we
also see Tommy Lee Jones character we
also see Howard Stark and Peggy Carter
all on the wall also is a deep deep cut
reference right here notice the code
they used to sneak into this secret
secret office the code is eight five
three nine online people have said that
this is a nod to patriot issue number
three since that comment came out in
august fifth 1939 so 85 39 also we get a
hint two Starks parents death at the
hands of the Winter Soldier in this
movie that's why it kind of comes full
circle in civil war but I didn't really
hit me when I first saw that movie also
t2 Easter egg check out what like what I
was wearing here as zoom in right about
here you'll notice that she's wearing a
necklace what's on that necklace oh it's
a little arrow and it's been confirmed
that this is a fun Easter egg towards
Hawkeye and this is an appointment we
all thought they were gonna get together
and the age old trunk kind of changed
all that not in a bad way just in a
confusing way we didn't get the retro
costume from in Captain America one not
the super old one with the cuffs and the
wings on the side but yeah close enough
also want to point out another awesome
moment when Bucky kicks that dude into
the engine oh my goodness that is so
violent and now let's list off a couple
of those insight targets that we see pop
up really really fast first up its Maria
Hill I didn't even realize that it
panned out from the back of her head
just zoomed out and then zoomed up into
the sky also president Matthew Ellis who
Ellis was the president in Iron Man 3
which is a nod to Warren Ellis a very
popular comic book writer but most
importantly Anthony Stark aka Tony Stark
aka Iron Man in Avengers tower there's
an Easter egg with an Easter egg here
you'll actually notice in this scene a
newly reborn
did Avengers tower how cool is that a
big a on the side also we see near the
end of the film that crossbones actually
survives getting a whole building
dropped on him then moving under the
post-credits scene we hear mention of
Captain America's colorful friends which
is a fund not to the Avengers also the
final final scene
Bucky in the Smithsonian looking at his
own monument this is the same look that
he kind of has in civil war is well
worth pointing out finally before I
leave you guys let's hit up some pop
culture and historical little Easter
eggs and hidden references that I was
able to find like this is the first non
paramount produced movie for Marvel also
Gary Sinise is the narrator in the
Smithsonian exhibit for Captain America
and his Howling Commandos quickly earned
their stripes also when the kid notices
Captain America hiding in plain sight
with a hat and an interview Chris Evans
explained how much he loved this because
it finally made sense to him this trope
of a kid identifying someone trying to
hide in plain sight it's because he's
lower than everybody else he's able to
look up past the hat and actually see
someone's face pause the line for Black
Widow where did Captain America learn
how to steal a car even though he
explains it's from the war this is
actually a fun not from the Captain
America movie from the 90s we didn't get
the line shall we play a game this is
from Black Widow and Captain America
actually gets this reference it's
actually from the movie wargames also in
this thing we hear about Operation
Paperclip which is actually a real thing
where America specifically took some
German scientists for themselves to you
know help them advance our own
technology or medicine or what have you
then moving forward to when we're in
Alexander Pierce's house where he's
meeting with the Winter Soldier notice
when he opens the fridge there's a jar
of something of Paul Newman's which is
actually kind of a fun nod and a tribute
to his friend Paul Newman when I
actually started in a bunch of movies
together like Butch Cassidy and the
Sundance Kid they're moving to Senator
Stern doing this very awkward whisper to
Sitwell hey is Birth the meme and I
thought that was worth mentioning then
we meet the doctor who helped save Nick
Fury's life it's actually a fun Easter
Egg because this is Joe Russo one half
of the directing team for this movie and
Civil War and Avengers
anymore and coming into the very end of
this movie we see on Nick Fury's grave
the path of the righteous man Ezekiel
25:17 which of course is a very funny
Easter egg - Pulp Fiction if you didn't
know Sammy al Jackson was in that
and finally Stanley is cameo he's the
guard at the Smithsonian who is totally
gonna lose his job because Captain
America broke into a National Museum and
somehow you did not hear him yes you're
definitely gonna be fired and that's it
for me guys let me know what your
favorite Easter Egg was in the comments
down below or on twitter at only stupid
answers you ain't got those dang vowels
from stupid make sure you like this
video comment share it with your friends
and subscribe to make sure you check out
all of my other MCU rewatch breakdowns
on this channel barely made it through
that sentence I'm Sam basher and I'll
see you next time